[Music]
james thank you for being here you got
me bobo
bobo i'll call you bobo okay
only cops and judges call me james okay
bobo good to see you bobo i see you
you're really staring at me bobo
oh it's okay it's cool it's cool bubba
we're all friends here uh you are we
gotta get right into this you are a
squatchologist
you are very serious about this you
believe bigfoot exists
believes for stuff you can't see i know
they exist you know he exists and they
they exist there's more than one bigfoot
they're species they're like a primate
probably in the homo genus right okay so
you've seen big people say being like
yeah yeah have you seen bigfoot yeah
yeah i have you've seen him yourself
sword of god okay well uh you you have
not captured him though on video
uh
you have no photographs you have no film
you have no nothing no
i never had the equipment before we
started doing the show
and i haven't seen one since 2007
so the last time i saw one i
we just got we got the equipment like
two weeks later this rich guy wally buys
this equipment now and i got the
equipment two weeks later i would have
had i would have had it it was only like
70 feet away
but you had no you were looking for
bigfoot but had no recording equipment
well we did not not thermals i mean that
stuff was like 35 grand you know right
well good thing wally came along yeah
you've gotten a look at him described
what is i mean you've seen bigfoot what
does a bigfoot look like
well a lot of pretty much everyone here
has probably seen it the patterson film
the 1967 where it goes walk up the creek
and looks back
yeah but many people think that's a guy
in a bigfoot costume well dude there's a
lot of people think that moon is made of
cheese but talk to like an
astrophysicist you're gonna find out
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a that's a good point most most
people believe that moon is made of
cheese
whatever in the old days i understand
but okay let's look at we have there are
three
uh there is just some existing photos of
bigfoot there's that one do you think
that's authentic is that a big there's
that one right here
that's fake that one and what about
there's this one here which looks like
just bigfoot's doing yoga with a ball
what's that is that a real one yeah yeah
that's a real bigfoot i just camped
there a couple weeks ago in pennsylvania
so jacob's photo these guys got on the
game camera there's two photos and you
also see right before before and after
that some bear cubs came in there and
bear cubs black bears around north
america generally the same size same
time of year this thing's totally
different size um jane goodall looked at
the primatologist chimpanzee lady yeah
and said you know that's that's a
primate bear experts have looked at it
and said it's not a bear some people say
it's a bear but it's not definitive but
so you can tell the difference between
someone in a bigfoot costume in the
actual bigfoot well the pattern should
have been filmed we were talking about
earlier the 67. no human on earth meets
those proportions like you can't extend
from the elbow to the
to the shoulder or from or from the knee
to the hip i have you seen my
proportions i
i
oh thank you john tesh and i both could
be a bigfoot i remember we both have
extremely long legs and i have elongated
arms and i roam the woods nude at night
often
these are all true stories
um you do
okay you try to attract bigfoot when
you're looking for them how are you
trying to attract bigfoot um what would
be bigfoot i'm sorry i keep saying
bigfoot is though there are one we all
know there are hundreds of thousands
well there's probably between two and
six thousand in north america roughly
we'll have a better idea in this dna
study so there's a lot of dna samples
been turned in dna samples from bigfoot
yeah yeah they they've got new
techniques to extract dna um well what
dna do you have of bigfoots
um mostly it's coming from hair like
hair samples already had that the
morphology the hair the the it's uh
unidentified primate it's been collected
in north america there's hundreds of
samples so it's all hair that's all the
details no no there's um
there's some blood samples where they've
crossed barbed wire fences and i don't
want to get too into it but uh a guy
shot two of them two years ago in
northern california and they he brought
in a chunk of the leg from the adult he
shot a young one an adult one and that's
the basis of the whole study really yeah
but it's
not supposed to say
your whole show is about finding bigfoot
and you're not allowed to say that they
found bigfoot and have a piece of him
everyone's signed into asia but i didn't
but uh everyone else that's working on
it science so then you're allowed to
talk about it we've got a chunk of a
bigfoot somewhere they do we've got dna
from bigfoot we've got hair we've got
blood they map the genome yeah they've
got they've got do they is there semen
is there bigfoot semen i'm trying to
collect that right now
i'll take one for the team
i'm dedicated you gotta do what you
gotta do
do what
no
you need him in a hotel
bigfoot